[Musique]
bien
Ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui oui
[Musique]
et bien non
je ne sais pas
en général ne m'appelez pas technique
a explosé et Hannibal avec 28 étant un navire non
c'est une prison de conception
rooney n'est rien rien 58
drôle
pour cela
trois mois, nous constatons une réduction
d'eau
la culture devra étendre la vision
d'investissement hectométrique au Yémen qui
nous pouvons d'ici est le théâtre
[Applaudissements]
d
[Musique]
heureusement que la musique m'a sauvé
ne pas tomber dans la folie et
désespoir et j'ai pu me permettre
faire une chanson qui divertit
des gens qui divertissent mais en même temps
recevoir un bon message et c'est précisément
ce qui se passe actuellement dans le monde
parce que c'est devenu viral
[Musique]
Hmm
C'est la première fois que j'essayais le
chante-le depuis mon balcon à mes voisins
Eh bien, ils m'ont dénoncé et la police est arrivée
parce qu'un voisin voisin ne le pensait pas
prudent, cela ne lui semblait pas commode
il a bien aimé mais heureusement les policiers
ils comprenaient l'autorité et
autorités de son état
de la municipalité compris et
ils m'ont permis de rester calme seulement ça
Voulez-vous le baisser un peu pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Non
est appelé à utiliser
[Musique]
contient de l'eau qui a bénéficié
du même sexe
[Musique]
et
C'est plus
Ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh
[Musique]